qui par ailleurs a pris la parole
aujourd'hui lors d'une visio-conférence
qui a réuni les ministres des sports de
plusieurs pays s'est exprimé à
l'ouverture de cette conférence pour
réclamer une nouvelle fois l'exclusion
des sportifs Russes et biélorus des
prochains JO alors que le Comité
international olympique plaid plutôt
pour qu'il puisse participer sous
barrière neutre on en parle avec notre
invité Lucas Aubin docteur en
géopolitique à l'Iris spécialiste de la
Russie et du sport également auteur de
la sportocratora sous Vladimir Poutine
une géopolitique du sport russe merci
d'être avec nous sur France 24 il y a un
bras de fer entre le CIO et l'Ukraine
sur cette question auparavant le Sillé
était plutôt aligné sur une exclusion
des sportifs russes alors pourquoi ce
revirement
alors il y a plusieurs raisons mais la
principale c'est que le 24 février
dernier lorsque le CIO a demandé en fait
aux fédérations internationales du sport
d'exclure la Russie et le Belarus du
sport mondial en réalité le CIO faisait
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire
entre guillemets au regard de sa
politique en réalité le CIO promeut ce
qu'on appelle la politique de la
politique c'est-à-dire qu'il se déclare
neutre en toute circonstances or en
prenant en position contre la Russie et
en faveur de l'Ukraine le CIO est sorti
de son apolitisme aujourd'hui il cherche
à y rentrer et à refaire à repromouvoir
pardon ça neutralité le problème étant
que effectivement Vladimir Poutine sur
le terrain n'a pas reculé d'un iota
concernant ses objectifs militaires et
stratégiques et de fait on a un
volodingski des pays baltes la Pologne
la Grande-Bretagne etc etc qui
s'opposent forcément à cette décision
alors depuis ce revirement que vous avez
décrit certains pays en soutien donc à
l'Ukraine menace de boycotter les
prochains JO le CIO dénonce le site
c'est menaces quelle pourrait être une
solution de compromis selon vous
pour le moment j'ai des difficultés à
imaginer un autre compromis que
l'exclusion entre guillemets pure et
simple des athlètes russes des JO de de
Paris 2020 4 je pense que si un athlète
russe participe à ces Jeux Olympiques
j'imagine très mal en tout cas l'Ukraine
voulait dire les athlètes ukrainien
décidaient de participer à l'événement
de façon tout à fait tout à fait normale
après d'ici là d'ici les JO de Paris
2024 la situation sur le terrain pourra
évoluer également il faut bien imaginer
que cette guerre dure maintenant depuis
un an on sait que les forces ukrainien
ont repris beaucoup de terrain depuis
quelques mois peut-être que cela va
continuer dans ce sens c'est évidemment
impossible de le dire pour le moment il
y a plusieurs scénarios possibles on
sait que le CIO avait un moment donné
évoquer l'idée de faire signer aux
athlètes russes une charte selon
laquelle il se prononcerait contre le
régime de Vladimir Poutine et
l'opération militaire spécial comme on
l'appelle en Russie
en Ukraine néanmoins ça paraît également
très compliqué de mettre en place une
telle réforme une telle mesure ne
serait-ce que parce que aujourd'hui en
Russie vous êtes puni par la loi si vous
vous prononcez contre cette opération
militaire spéciale à l'est de l'Ukraine
il y a plusieurs scénarios possibles
quel scénario servirait le plus Vladimir
Poutine et sa propagande
pour le moment le scénario ou les
athlètes russes reviendraient sous
bannière neutre serait une victoire une
demi-victoire en tout cas pour Vladimir
Poutine puisque si le sport a été une
des premières institutions finalement à
couper les ponts avec le régime russe on
se souvient que les sanctions ont été
prononcées le 25 février 2022 donc au
lendemain de l'invasion si le sport a
été premier à couper les ponts l'un des
premiers il sera alors l'un des premiers
à restaurer ces ponts s'il a accepté les
athlètes sous bannières neutre et alors
ce serait pour la ligne Poutine la porte
ouverte finalement à une normalisation
de sa puissance à l'échelle
internationale et c'est le pari de
Vladimir Poutine c'est ce n'est pas le
court terme mais bien le moyen et le
long terme lui et c'est élites pense
effectivement que
les opinions occidentales que l'Occident
de manière générale va se diviser à
mesure que cette guerre durera puisque
finalement cette union n'est pas faite
pour durer merci beaucoup Lucas au bain
pour votre éclairage aujourd'hui sur
France 24